in the modern world our opinions and our
Deeds have never been further apart in
the past any opinion and any deed would
have ended up being stress tested at
some point if you say that you're a good
person in 20 000 years ago around the
campfire and yet every time you go
hunting you don't bring back meat for
everybody else you just bring it for
your family eventually someone's gonna
go come on you keep saying that you're a
good person whereas on Twitter no one
ever actually ends up scrutinizing the
way that you show up in the real world
you can be the most empathetic
pro-female person in the world and you
go home beat your wife and nobody knows
well for the most part nobody knows when
people get rumbled for it that's why it
feels so satisfying to us yes I think
that it's because we have this sense
that a lot of the people who push real
virtual beauty or push digital blackface
is something that should genuinely be
cared about are just doing performative
empathy I don't think that we believe
that it's true